Chuck Todd is a Democrat activist but
they have to keep the game going in some
weird way because too many of us are
seeing behind the curtain so every now
and again they have to ask somewhat of a
critical question so it doesn't seem
like their total partisan hacks here's
Chuck Todd acknowledging that most
people two-thirds of us actually are
just not interested in what Joe Biden
selling when President Biden addresses
the nation on Tuesday night he will be
speaking to a skeptical public despite
the low unemployment rate a stronger
than expected midterm performance for
his political party and a string of
legislative accomplishments the
president's job rating sits at just 45
percent his poll numbers are even lower
on his handling of the economy foreign
policy and specifically the war in
Ukraine two-thirds of Voters have
reservations who are very uncomfortable
with the idea of Biden running for a
second term yeah two-thirds of people I
guess don't have brain damage that seems
a little high to me frankly but an
increasing amount of people are going
okay the guy's not cognitively fit
Chinese spy disastrous with what
withdrawal of Afghanistan what's going
on with the economy we're pissed about
the Jabs nobody got fired over anything
like all of the stuff so every now and
again the corporate media has to and in
some ways what they're doing even when
they when they criticize them as
carrying order because they want to get
the base riled up to make sure that the
base comes out and votes
[Music]